la reanudación de la liga de campeones
debía traer esperanza y lo ha hecho no
solamente a los hinchas del fútbol sino
también a la gente en general porque era
como que la vida volviera a retomar su
curso después de meses de confinamiento
por causa del coronavirus en el mundo
entero
lisboa se convirtió en la sede de la
fase final de la liga de campeones-
acogiendo a los 8 mejores equipos que
quedan todavía que quedaban todavía en
competición
lisboa ganó este premio y esto le
debería significar el regreso en masa de
los turistas en parte portugal ganó
llegamos este privilegio por el buen
manejo que ha tenido de la epidemia de
coronavirus aquí en europa y sin embargo
no se vive un ambiente tan festivo como
debería cuando se trata sobre todo de la
liga de campeones porque no se ven
multitudes de hinchas en las calles en
parte porque los partidos se disputan a
puerta cerrada sin público sin embargo
si nos hemos cruzado con varios hinchas
sobre todo del parís and drama y del all
anti que lionel los dos clubes franceses
como ustedes ven a mis espaldas
vienen a baires aquí en el centro de
lisboa para ver los partidos de sus
equipos en todo caso se espera que esta
liga de campeones traiga unas ganancias
a la capital de portugal de unos 50
millones de euros